yeah it makes a makes a lot of sense
obviously elon uh has done a fantastic
job building that business uh he now has
he's turning his uh his attention to
twitter uh he a couple of things here so
like one just like what's your general
read on the whole twitter situation are
you a fan of elon doing this do you
think it's a distraction how do you read
it uh to start well i'm going to tell
you some things pomp you know a lot of
there's a lot of misinformation going
around about this whole twitter thing
and i just read in the paper that the
head of the cia flew out to saudi arabia
last month and i think it was to tell
them that we were taking twitter back
from them
and that's what this is really about
whether people want to
you know
worry about donald trump being on the
platform oh no god forbid you know the
right wing
might have free speech or or this or
that but it's really about his foreign
interference in our elections in our
democracy it's gotten to a
horrible situation in america and in
western governments now with the war in
ukraine it's become so obvious the
misinformation
um that's put out on twitter daily the
constant attacks the bots
it became a national security issue for
the united states became a major issue
for
uh tesla because tesla uses twitter as
its main
advertising vehicle and elon felt it was
time to step in and take this asset back
from the foreign actors that have been
manipulating it so a couple of questions
first is uh you think saudi arabia owns
twitter or like like what they do on
twitter they own six percent of twitter
but i think they control twitter
internally
and in what way like do you think it's
part of like the content moderation
decisions do you think that they've got
some sort of leverage over the executive
team like tell me more about that
i think they've implanted people in
executives from all the way through the
company that are acting to
uh help with the misinformation
campaigns that have been so effective on
social media saudi arabia and russia
being the two biggest beneficiaries of
these misinformation campaigns
we have a very insidious
thing going on in social media and with
instagram and facebook we have no
ability to get control of these assets
because zuckerberg controls it like the
great overlord of misinformation
um and we're seeing it in countries like
india where modi has used it to oppress
people and really
fervent nationalism against the muslim
pop population in india and and it
creates violence and and you know
oppression essentially so zuckerberg and
samberg are perfectly fine with all of
it as long as they make money um and i
think
people like elon had had enough of this
stuff so so you know now
he's stepping in and using his
considerable financial might to do
something i think that's going to be a
benefit to our society and very
profitable for ultimately twitter
shareholders so he my understanding is
he's basically putting up some of his
tesla shares as collateral uh and then
also getting a you know bunch of
financing and kind of putting together
what is going to end up being a somewhat
complex deal as a tesla shareholder do
you worry about the tesla shares being
uh collateralized to help finance the uh
the acquisition of twitter
no
what what do you like like how do you
it's it's a 20 it's like a 25 margin
position so it's not like he's highly
leveraged in it and and quite frankly i
think the tesla shares
are the most valuable shares in the
stock market so you know
i i don't really spend much time
worrying about that either because
you know
like when elon sold shares last week it
was like to a benefit of the public
because he's not like not operating
tesla he went from owning 17 of tesla to
16 of tesla and it pushes the price down
and allows other investors to buy tesla
stock at a cheaper price when we all
know the information that's out there
that tesla is executing brilliantly
right now in a product that's in such
high demand that they really just can't
supply it and um what i i'm seeing from
yesterday is it looks and this is what's
going to happen next so so maybe this is
the first place i'm really saying this
is that uh
tesla's prepared to build a second
gigafactory in texas and a second giga
factory in shanghai and i expect formal
announcements for that fairly soon hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time